nowadays rooftop solar panels are a
common sight in american suburbs helping
the solar industry grow exponentially
over the last couple of decades but what
about renters and small businesses
without the same resources and access to
this form of clean energy well there's
an energy model offering to change that
community solar promises to give
everyone a chance to be a part of the
climate solution and save money in the
process
in southeast washington dc a once
abandoned and vacant lot is now prime
farmland this is up and running up and
running and we actually have slots open
slots open yes a landscape loaded with
ground-mounted solar panels generating
clean affordable energy to low in
moderate income households and local
businesses even renters without roof
space can benefit crystal hansley has
helped make those connections
this is a 510 kilowatt system and i
service around 100 customers and are
they mostly people who live around here
yes so this solar farm connects to its
local utility and anyone who receives
that bill so any dc customer anyone
that's in the same location of the
utility can tap into this farm scores of
other projects are cropping up in and
around cities part of a growing energy
model called community solar that
includes hansley's company we solar if
you're looking for residual income and
you're looking to create ways to help
the planet save money
create a benefit for your local
community i would definitely consider
working with community solar companies
homeowner erica ruffin signed up hoping
to save 25 percent on her electric bill
we saw that we can actually take
advantage of solar power via the farms
we knew right away that's what we wanted
to do my husband actually lost his job
last year due to covent so we try to
save money any way that we can
still some communities are hesitant
mainly because they've been left out of
the renewable energy discussion today we
are celebrating the fact that more than
100 homes in our community have been
equipped with solar panels through the
solar for all programs d.c mayor muriel
bowser in the department of energy and
environment launched a program called
solar for all which works with the dc
sustainable energy utility to connect a
hundred thousand low-income residents to
solar by 2032.
our expertise is the construction and
the technical financing that goes with
developing the projects that's why new
columbia solar partnered with hansley
when we look at sites sam walker is
their vp of finance
you have to be innovative with the way
you you reach out to folks and groups
who can
leverage online communities leverage uh
church groups and other community
organizations to build a network to
build a local community of subscribers
for a project that way is is just much
more effective trust is key trust is
huge
there's one thing to develop a community
solar farm and then tell the community
be a part of it versus when you engage
the community from the beginning get
their insight into where you should do
the citing and the marketing and use
language that they're familiar with then
your project is more successful for her
to bring it to us to encourage our
involvement
was pretty impressive and i just prayed
reverend derek dewitt is the director of
the maryland baptist aged home in
baltimore after hearing hansley's pitch
he registered the 100 year old nursing
home with the white marsh solar farm
shortly before covid
minority communities play a part not
only in achieving net zero and engaging
in energy initiatives that's out there
but to have an opportunity for our
residents and constituents to save money
as well was very important i think we
started realizing savings in being
connected to the solar farm within about
60 days of signing up
savings can be anywhere from 10 to 50
percent and according to the solar
energy industries association through
2020 3.1 gigawatts of community solar
have been installed across 40 states in
the u.s that's about 500 000 households
it costs on average a million dollars to
develop a solar farm that can serve 150
subscribers costs that are further
subsidized so you have your traditional
green banks you have your corporate
sponsors you have your tax equity
investors and three or four players at
the table you're able to cap capitalize
the solar farm one of those corporate
sponsors is coffee giant starbucks
michael koburi is their chief
sustainability officer what we really
need more companies to do
is to invest in
renewable projects that increase the
amount of supply of clean renewable
energy
the company has pledged to shrink their
carbon footprint 50 percent by 2030 with
a seed investment of 97 million dollars
in new york state alone there's going to
be 400 starbucks stores that will
receive access to renewable energy there
are 24 000
households and local businesses that
will get access to clean renewable
energy as for the future hansley's
growing her business a first generation
college graduate who is the daughter of
a community activist she's taking wii
solar from subscription service to solar
project developer what's it gonna feel
like when you have that first solar farm
from beginning to end under your belt
it's going to be amazing it's going to
really represent where we're going in
this country to be able to support
minority women-owned business to create
equitable solar and to save people money
and decarbonizing our footprint it feels
amazing to be a part of that transition
well the d.c solar for all program has
already connected some 6 700 residents
since launching and hopes to subscribe
another 2000 by the end of this year
something companies like we solar can
achieve but again i
interviewed
these people back in july that number
the number of slots 2000 remains the
same so the hesitancy is is still very
very clear in part as you know because
of all the scammers who are in this
sector right so people want to put their
eyeballs on the person pitching they
also want to know the details so that's
so critical why people
like crystal are out there pitching the
way they are yeah really interesting